Alaska
fifteen thousand square miles of
paradise The Mill Road in no Road out
in this narrow strip of coastline
over 3 000 Alaskan black bear congregate
one of the densest populations of black
bear in the world
two banners for every square mile
right here right now
because there'll also be over tens of
thousands of salmon
I'm here to embed myself with the
Alaskan black bear to get down in where
they are
to learn their survival techniques
[Music]
there'll be no humans where I'm going
just me and the best
the Alaskan black bear has a small
window of time to make the most of the
salmon spawning in this network of bays
in southern Alaska
but it's a moment that gives me a brief
opportunity to see them in action
or I take one step into their territory
I'm meeting with local Wilderness guide
Dennis sadra
he spent decades observing black bears
in Prince William sound
he knows firsthand the challenges and
dangers of walking into Bear Country
tell me what I can expect out there um
the Bears you know they know that this
is their opportunity to put on their
weight you know the last probably six
weeks or so a bear is going to put on
the fact that he needs to get to the
winner and then winners are cold and
they're you know it's dark and they need
all this energy they've got to grab this
protein while they can it's a real
narrow window of opportunity what's
particularly uh dangerous for me in this
situation well you're going into their
feeding grounds you know we've had three
people killed in this state this year by
black bears you got to be cautious of
all of them any of them can can change
in the blink of an eye and especially
when you're in that close to them that's
when it happens you know
in order to stay safe I'll need to stay
focused
Prince William's sound has thousands of
miles of Base just like this one
Bears travel here from far and wide to
feed on the Salmon Run
getting in close enough to these Bears
to learn their survival techniques is
going to be challenging for me and my
crew
turn around
oh
this is magnificent
time to get into Bear Country and this
is perfect Bear Country
there are over a hundred thousand black
bears in Alaska and 3 000 in this region
alone
following the clues to their favorite
feeding grounds
will place me in Prime position to
observe these animals up close
see there's fish up here on the shore
but this is I can almost guarantee
that this fish is just a fish that's
died it's not from bear activity
see that rump
nutrient Rich lots of fat and oils in
the rump
the black bears are going to want to be
eating primarily the rump the brain out
of the males and the row the eggs out of
the females that's where all the
nutrients are if the Bears are feeding
well they'll focus on those parts of the
body of the fish if they're really
hungry they'll just eat the whole thing
these strategic fishing habits are a key
component of the black bear's survival
instincts
and they serve to maximize their energy
as winter approaches
when I find evidence of this efficient
feeding I'll know I'm on the right Trail
[Music]
what I hope and expect to find
moving up into here is bear scat that's
filled with decaying
salmon roll
and it'll indicate that I'm close to
Peter when it comes to finding a spot
where the Bears are feeding
all right I'm about to head up into the
bear zone so time
[Music]
along with me is a team of wildlife
cameramen following my journey
and covering as much of the black bear's
activity as possible
there it is my first science
and this bear Scott poop
his purplish bluish is full of berries
full of seeds
so this indicates to me earlier feeding
not current feeding this this could have
been here oh even a matter of a week it
depends on how much rain hits it makes
it dissolve at this point in the season
the Bears have moved on from berries
they're going to be taking full
advantage of the Salmon Run
as the window to feed rapidly closes
so this is earlier season feeding
what I want is current season feeding
the salmon
foreign
this here is not a human Trail
this is a Bear Trail they may be looking
around out in the bay
that they're feeding somewhere up here
and I'm basically following that trail
into their kitchen I hope
see this cat
doesn't have seeds and berries
it has salmon roll
salmon eggs and it stinks like fish
oh yeah I'm in the right place already
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
different Bears can favor different
fishing spots specific to their survival
needs a mother will fish in strategic
locations where her Cubs can climb a
tree to quickly evade predators
adolescent Bears will sometimes fight
with their peers for fishing spots only
to be chased off by an even bigger foe
a dominant male
an older bear with the confidence and
size to fish wherever and whenever he
wants
looks very promising to me
here we go
I'm already seeing salmon
oh it's unbelievable to see salmon in a
stream like this check it out
oh that's my first good sign the food is
here
oh look at this look at this
it's the beginning of their long journey
journey to get back to the exact place
where they were hatched
when Salmon hatch in a river that very
location is imprinted into their homing
instincts they'll always be able to
pinpoint this location after years of
migrating far out into the Pacific Ocean
in search of abundant food
it's thought that they're attuned to the
Earth's magnetic field using it like a
compass
this internal navigation system will one
day guide the salmon back to this exact
spot to spawn
as the Bear's own instincts drive them
here to feed
these fish have been swimming for
thousands of miles
evading sharks and whales and all kinds
of fish to make it here
I wanted to face the Bears
that's incredible
what they're doing here
this is all
that
he's gone in after the guts mostly went
for the brains oh that stinks brains
hump on the back and the eggs
if bears are being this picky
they're eating well here
they should be a very productive spot ah
look at that clear example of going
after just the eggs perfect example
[Applause]
see that
there they are Bear's done eating
just one of the caviar
left all the meat
ate out the eggs
with hibernation just around the corner
black bears have entered a survival
phase called hyperphagia
their appetites become voracious as they
eat to fatten up as preparation for
seven months of hibernation
in this Do or Die stage they can eat up
to 20 000 calories a day that's 10 times
more than a human eats daily
however they don't eat the Flesh of the
salmon to get that much needed energy
they target instead the brains
the fatty Dorsal fins and the eggs to
prevent themselves from starving to
death through their winter sleep
the black bear is remove what they need
with surgical precision
and move on to the next fish
leaving Telltale Carnage behind
and that's how it's done just like that
so if I a bumbling clumsy slow humid
can do that imagine what a creature
has been doing this
since its existence
can do how quickly they can get their
mail and lots of it
there's signs everywhere
yeah this place was like a salmon
slaughterhouse
the only question is will they be coming
back to feed here again
I see one there
[Music]
this mother and her cub is
that black bear spend over a year
raising their cubs
forming a strong family bond
mothers not only feed and groom their
cubs
they also cuddle and play games with
their offspring
above all else though mother bears are
constantly vigilant protecting the Cubs
from predators which can even include
other black bears
[Applause]
what an incredible morning of activity
look at this place
it's a bit of a bowl like all the area
it's like a bowl shaped so if I get up
just sort of slightly up a bit in a
setup camp
I have a good view all the way around
all right
foreign
let's see what happens
bears are definitely feeding in this
area
so setting up my Camp here gives me two
advantages
keeping me off the bear is beaten path
and giving me a clear view of any bears
that might come through here during the
night
or into the morning
let's just see what tomorrow brings
I didn't hear any activity last night
no fishing down by the salmon
slaughterhouse
nothing
black bears can be highly adverse to
humans and their first instinct is
usually to avoid us if at all possible
I'm hoping my presence here hasn't
caused them to scatter
I guess
good for me
also good for the Bears
they're certainly your feet on the
salmon but they're not shy to eat the
berries at the same time
that's why there's cat you're so full of
it all the time
let's go
if I continue to track along the
waterways where the Bears have been
fishing I've got a much better chance at
finding them
I can't see I'm just gonna follow this
Creek along here
the crew has to hang way back of me
there
thank you
it gets too close to me
lost my cover
because if I'm going to have any kind of
encounter at all I've got to go in alone
and I've got to go inside I'm like
[Applause]
I guess they think I'm a bear
ah
that's some serious Carnage
this really helps the Auntie now
you can see how productive this Creek is
for the black bears
fish that are taken out and not even
eaten yeah that's one here
pulled from the creek
not even touched I mean what are they
doing practicing
that's a bear that wasn't very hungry
maybe just having some fun
one thing is certain if they're leaving
salmon untouched
it means this area has more fish than
the Bears could possibly eat
this is even salmon Row in their
footsteps
Bears can travel many miles driven by
the scent of food
but this abundant fishing spot littered
with freshly eaten salmon is all the
evidence I need to tell me that they're
all congregating
here
it's only a matter of time before I find
them
[Music]
here's the thing
for the most part the Blackberry
how many sounds like here in the forest
make me
nervous right now
for the most part the black bear
they'll bet down in an area where it can
still see
survey its domain
I'm not too far away not right down in
close but just sort of mid-range and
that's what I've got right behind you
right here check this out
all right
all of that grass is pushed down by
black bears napping maybe even spending
the night
no that says that a bear at some point
decided this is his meal I just want
anybody to touch it this must be
somebody's favorite spot to sit and eat
this might actually make a great place
to uh
set of a blind that's it
talk about
Goldilocks picking a bed to sleep in
let's hope that it's a nice medium-sized
bear
[Music]
with bear Trails bare beds and fish
Carnage all throughout the salmon
slaughterhouse this is clearly a high
traffic area
and from inside this camouflage blind
I should hopefully be able to watch the
Bears undetected
that's perfect
as a rainstorm Moves In
it's a clear reminder that winter is not
far behind
the weather could be an asset
a bare sense of smell could cover a
radius of over 20 miles
but the rain does help mask my scent
in this blind and in the rain
would be hard to smell as I am to see
it's thought that the black bear is
nocturnal but it's actually avoidance of
humans when you go to places where they
don't need to avoid humans you know
active all hours of the day you know
black bears need to forage about 20
hours of their day for food gaining 35
of their body weight
so they do need to be active during the
day so they'll be out there
my question is when are they coming back
to here
[Applause]
[Music]
while I'm in this blind I'm hoping to
get a good visual on the bears that are
feeding in the area
[Music]
you can tell the
feet part from the males by their
slightly smaller behinds and they're
less blocky and stocky bodies
they weigh about 175 pounds and they're
lighter and sleeker looking with less
rounder faces than the adult males
it's the males that'll be the real find
and under this camouflage I'm hoping to
spot them while remaining
unseen
[Music]
my mission to embed myself with Alaskan
black bears and witness their survival
skills in action
has proven to be challenging
the bad weather reduces their visibility
dulls their hearing and even
disadvantages their sense of smell
all of this makes them too nervous to
venture out into the open
their sense of smell is one of their
greatest survival attributes
seven times more powerful than that of a
Bloodhounds it can detect sense from
miles away
but the rain can interfere with this
extraordinary ability
[Applause]
this rain just keeps getting worse
I haven't seen a bear for hours
I'm not having any luck here I'm
guessing that this rain is keeping 80 of
them
kidnapped at the forest so I'm gonna
hike the hills and see if I can find
them myself if they aren't going to come
to me I'm going to go to them
I think it's a young walking through the
bush maybe a young female I'm guessing
about a three-year-old
[Applause]
hungry
it's young around there's a little
chance that there's any big males close
by they don't want to mess with a big
mouth so you see a young adult it's
generally on its own maybe another young
adult it won't go near moms and cops and
won't go in here big mouths
with an adolescent
you really don't know what you're
dealing with
adolescents and females in the area
the question is
where are the larger males
[Music]
trying to see a young bear out in the
open
but there are other clues that show me a
dominant male is nearby
oh here we go
there we go
that's some scratches check this out
these deep scratches here
from there
just like everything else they do
it's a point of survival so the Bears
will come here they'll make their
markings just tells all the other bears
this is how big I am
and whether or not you need to I think
you can challenge me
[Music]
all right
and judging by the scratches on this
tree there's a lot of bear communication
going on around here
[Music]
this persistent rain may be keeping the
Bears at Bay but the good news is that
it's also causing the Creeks to rise
bringing the next wave of spawning
salmon rain or shine the Abundant salmon
will eventually be too enticing for the
Bears to ignore
all this water this rainness runoff
fresh water as it rises from the storms
is a very good thing without the rain
the migration of the Sandler wouldn't be
triggered everything would be too dry
these salmon are called
and they come thousands of miles
back to this one Creek
spawn
they were born here they left they made
it all the way down to the ocean that's
why I'm thousands of miles
[Applause]
and when they were ready they came right
back to here
likely to within an inch or three of
where they were born just so they can
lay their eggs and end their life
salmon used nearly all of their energy
to return to their spawning sites once
they've spawned they die soon after
if the black bears are going to make it
through winter they'll need to Feast on
the last of the spawning salmon before
they perish
with the season rapidly closing
the Bears are running out of time
this weather is incredibly frustrating
soaked from above and soaked from within
that's one right along the Ridgeline now
okay
that's my blind
that's what embarrassed
black bears aren't territorial
instead they have a perimeter or
critical space wherever they go
any bear or human that comes within this
space
risks confrontation
[Music]
that's my blind
that's where the bear is at
this close distance staying still is my
safest bet
the black bear can run 35 miles per hour
out in the open here I wouldn't stand a
chance
if this black bear approaches
I'll need to assert dominance by holding
my ground
making myself appear large and by
speaking in a loud commanding voice
If This Were a grizzly
I'd play dead but with a black bear the
best option is often to stand
and fight
[Applause]
get right back to me I'm blind again
leave the crew some distance away just
trying to
capture the action of what happens
around me
turn it up
wait a minute
oh boy
somebody decided to kind of take it out
on my stamp
it's on its side and it was not windy
I take that as a sign that somebody
didn't want me here
a tough luck
I'm still here
Not only was it pushed over but it was
also drag that way away
the flipping over of my blind could just
be the work of a curious adolescent
or it could be from a male bear
aggressively defending its space
either way it's likely that there are
more bears nearby
time to get inside for now
[Music]
thank you
so I'm sitting in a blind
that very clearly
a bear
has pushed over
a little upset that was here maybe just
a little bit curious
surrounded by dead salmon
all around me I'm also actually right on
the spot of where a bear sleeps maybe
that's the bear that pushes over
and I'm eating a salmon sandwich
just doesn't seem wise does it
as the rain continues my chances of
finding a large adult male bear gets
smaller with an intelligence level
similar to the great apes bears are very
clever at hiding themselves
but I do have something else I can try
for a little bit of this action
if there's a big male black bear out
there
he's much too clever to show himself
while I'm around
I'm hoping these remote cameras can
outsmart him
there are ample feeding opportunities
along this Creek
so I'm spacing my cameras out to try to
cover as much of the area as I can
that way I should be able to observe
when any bear comes out to Feast on
salmon
[Music]
I'll do
with such highly developed sensors
it's almost impossible not to alert
these Bears to my presence
no matter how cautious I am
by using trail cameras I can take myself
out of the equation for the night
let's see what happens after the sun
goes down in Bear Country
[Music]
check out some of these trail cams after
days of tracking I still haven't seen a
dominant male black bear so I've set up
a series of trail cams along the creek
to increase my chances of seeing one in
action
here
that ain't right that's supposed to be
closed it was close when I left it
batteries have been pulled out
had them pull down my trail cams before
[Applause]
I put that in see if I can turn it on
still
yeah there we go
okay play videos
okay
hard not found
good Lord
he ate the card
well that's just not fair
[Applause]
all right next
I'll be looking at the footage they're
over here looking at me
okay
nothing
let's go check the others
[Applause]
drill cams draw cams what did you find
okay
okay I got one
oh that's awesome
oh that's a beauty
this could be the bear I've been looking
for all this time
this is working but the deal here is
that this trail cam is Downstream for me
I'm slightly upstream and they're not
coming up to me what I'm going to do is
take my trail cams and just set them all
up
in a bit of a semi Arc and if a bear
comes through the idea is it'll walk
right through my Gauntlet of trail cams
let's see what's going on
I don't have many chances left to
outsmart these bears
salmon have almost finished their run
look at that
all that white is rot they're literally
rotting while they swim
many of them dying and not even making
it up to stream
that's going to Signal the end of the
season for the salmon
running on the clock for the Bears
figure it's time to go next level
I have to double up on my rain gear
for obvious reasons the weather's not
going to quit and neither will I reality
is this is a hotbed of activity I know
that by the trail cams I'm tired of
hanging out on the outskirts of my
campus I want to be right on top of
these guys
so up that tree which is where I'm going
it's time for the tree stand
I don't want to be too high up I'm going
to go maybe 12 15 feet tops
down on the ground my tracks and my
scent betray my presence
up here in the stand I'll have a prime
view of the area
and it'll make it a lot harder for the
Bears to spot me
this should give me the edge
to watch them up close
all right set for the night
so the tree stand with the help of my
crew is in place all I need now
is for my crew to leave
and the Bears Too arrive
it's a good view from here
[Music]
it was running over at my drill camp
this one is a classically nervous
adolescent bear
you can tell this young bear is nervous
through his body language
he moves with hesitation
looking over his shoulder and always
anticipating trouble
a mature male bear will tend to move
with confidence
slow and deliberate
he often plays it cool and ignores the
other bears
unless he's forced to act
worried about it
so he's jittery
it's clear that the salmon are keeping
these bears in the bowl
but is the end of the salmon run
approaches I'm hoping that the crew and
I can find the dominant male before he
Retreats for hibernation
in the dark it's not going to be easy to
distinguish a juvenile bear
from an alpha male
you can't see anything
this is creepy
it's a big nail
[Music]
this is creepy
it's a big male
size of them
so there was a huge
I can't track him in the dark
daylight will give me a chance to search
for him in the woods and finally get a
close-up look at the bear that's been
avoiding me
up in that direction
[Music]
I know so if I keep going this dream
should lead into a big saltwater Lagoon
look at this
that is fresh
it's got this size could be the mark of
a large bear
it can't be far away
[Applause]
eating and defecating as they go
cabbage
is there munching on this munching on
Barry's head I guess those are the
appetizers and we all know what the meal
is it's swimming in this Creek
plenty of it
[Applause]
further down with a creek empties into a
saltwater Lagoon
my camera crew have caught up with our
Target
he's gonna be about 300 pounds
wow it's it's absolutely
finally a dominant male black bear
feasting on salmon
isn't too noisy okay
this huge male is too engrossed in
fishing to notice the crew's camera
on its hind legs that bear is likely
about seven feet tall
and a male that size is not going to be
challenged by any other bears in this
area
this is his domain
all right
Bears keep certain critical spaces all
to themselves usually to protect their
feeding grounds
and this male has the place all to
himself
the salmon are all thrashing around
their last bit of energy exerted on
their final run
with seven months of hibernation about
to begin
this is the last opportunity for this
black bear to eat as many calories as it
can
beautiful
[Music]
it's been incredible to witness these
instinctual Hunters at work
[Music]
they're finally tuned senses are key to
their survival
they are the Bear's guidance system
telling it where to feed
and its alarm system alerting it to
risks
it's these
insect the black bear the amazing
survivalist
of the Alaskan wilderness
[Music]